[Music]
welcome back
so we've been talking a lot about
turbulent fluid flows
and today i'm going to start deriving
the reynolds average
navier-stokes equations or the rand's
equations
which is one of our most powerful tools
for modeling
complex turbulent fluid flows okay
so i'm going to jump right in we're
going to start with
writing down the navy or stokes
equations we're going to
decompose the flow field into an average
and a fluctuating component
and we're going to see kind of how that
makes these equations easier or harder
to simulate
okay so navier stokes u t
the time derivative of u plus u
dot grad of u
equals minus gradient of the pressure
plus one over reynolds number
uh laplacian of u so this is our
diffusion term
and we're going to talk about
incompressible navier stokes
so i'm also going to have that the
divergence of u
is equal to zero so again this comes
from
conservation laws so this is mass
conservation
and this is momentum conservation and we
could derive those
uh by essentially writing down
conservation volume integrals
and then use stokes and gauss's theorems
to get
the navier-stokes equations in velocity
or vorticity
okay good now the reynolds average navy
or stokes equations
essentially what we're going to do is
we're going to take
our flow field variable u
and we're going to decompose it into a
average
component and a fluctuating component so
u is a function of space and time
okay u is a function of x and t and
we're going to write this
as an average component given by u bar
which is just a function of x so we're
going to average in time
and average out all the fluctuations
and we're going to also have a
fluctuating component
u prime of x and t
okay good and i want to point out at
this point
my u variable is really a vector
quantity so u
is really like um you know u of x
and t is u
v and w okay
and so we can decompose each of these
into u
bar of x plus little u
prime v bar of x plus little
v prime and w bar of x plus little w
prime okay so i just want to be very
explicit that this is a
vector partial differential equation in
u v and w
and i'm just using the variable u to
denote uh
you know these are all vectors okay
good and vector u we're going to
decompose into the average flow and the
fluctuating components
and so uh why would we do this first off
so
i mean i think it's actually really good
to ask these why
questions uh it turns out that this is a
really good idea for modeling
this uh partial differential equation
with less degrees of freedom than you
would normally need to to model on a
computer
but historically a lot of the reason we
look at
average equations is because our
measurements
were not spatially resolved so back
before computers back
before laser sheets made it possible to
image a whole
experimental velocity field at one time
instant
if i had a fluid flow like a pipe flow
something like this float through a pipe
i might only be able to measure one
point in space with a single hot wire
measurement probe
but i could measure a really long time
signature of that point
and then i'd move that hot wire over and
i'd measure another point
and another point in another point and
so what i'm going to end up getting
is the average field the average
velocity field at each point
in in space this u bar of x
that's averaged uh at each point in in
space i'm averaging all of the time
points
even though the individual instantaneous
flow field might be
turbulent and fluctuating and unsteady
we're going to average that out
so that's what this u bar of x is and
the way we actually compute u bar
is really simple i literally take
u bar and i'm going to average
u of x and t with respect to time
from 0 to big t and i'm going to take
the limit as that big t goes to infinity
i'm going to average for long
enough that this converges okay that's
called
stationarity so i'm going to take the
limit
as t goes to infinity of this integral
and that's how i'm going to take the
mean flow i'm literally at every point
in space
i'm going to average out time and then
i'm going to move it over to the next
point in x
the next point and that's how i'm going
to build this u bar
and u prime is literally defined as
everything else
i take my flow field minus my mean flow
and those are all of my fluctuating
components
okay good now what we're going to do
is now in uh the navy or stokes
equations
this describes all of the fluid flow in
a turbulent flow
across all of the scales the big
vortices the medium vortices the teeny
tiny vortices
all of it but to solve this on a
computer
generally speaking i have to chop up my
domain into millions or
billions of degrees of freedom and it's
super duper expensive to resolve the
biggest
structures and the smallest structures
in the same simulation
and so instead what we might want to do
is we might want to model
what are the big quantities of interest
you know when i'm developing or
designing a wing for an aircraft
i might not care about every minor
vortex i care about what's the drag
on that wing or what's the lift on that
wing is it going to separate
or stay attached at a different angle of
attack and so those are questions i
might be able to answer just by looking
at u
bar of x the kind of average flow
quantities
and the first few kind of statistical
moments of this fluctuating component
and it might be much much simpler to
model the mean flow and a few
statistical moments like the variance of
this for example
than to model the full navier stokes in
all of their complexity
and so what we're going to do in this
lecture and in the next lecture
is we're going to take this this is
called the reynolds decomposition
we're going to take this reynolds
decomposition and we're going to plug it
into our
our divergence free condition and we're
going to plug it into our momentum
equation
and we're going to see what happens to
the terms we're going to see if we can
simplify
and get a simplified model just for the
mean flow or just for the turbulating
the turbulence fluctuations okay good
and there's a few facts you need to know
before we can do this that are going to
make this a lot easier in practice for
us to compute this
okay so a few properties of these time
averages
is the following so the first one that's
kind of obvious
is that u prime if i time
average u prime that equals zero
because i i literally said u prime is
everything
that is not in the time average of u so
we've already subtracted out the time
average
this thing is zero centered it's it has
a zero mean
so the mean of u prime is zero okay
another one is that it's
uh this satisfies linearity so
if i average u plus v that's the same as
averaging u
plus average of v same thing
i can't double average if i take the
average of u twice i just get the
average
that's just u bar um there's some others
like if i take
a bar times b
and i bar that whole thing that's the
same as
a bar b bar okay
i'll show you one that's not true in a
minute it's uh actually i'll do that
right now because it's so important
a dot b bar
is not equal to a bar
b bar that's super important this is one
of the most important ones
and the last one that's also extremely
important it's going to make our life a
lot easier when we plug this
into here is that if i have the partial
of a with respect to some variable let's
say it's
uh x or y or z
and if i take the time average of that
derivative
it's equal to the derivative of
the time average with respect to that
variable
x and i'm using a b notation i switched
here
that's because i got i was looking
through lex smith's notes
and he uses a's and b's so i got a
little caught up here but the two kind
of
some of the most important ones for us
are this derivative property
so if i time average a derivative it's
the same as the derivative of the time
average
and this inequality that if i
take a dot b and time average
it is not the same as a time average
times b
time average so notice here that u is
zero mean
it is not zero variance so i also have
that u
prime squared if i time average that
this is not equal to zero and this is an
incredibly
important property so this
means that even though our fluctuations
are have zero mean
their variances and their higher moments
are non-zero they're non-trivial
and they're actually important in these
dynamics we're going to have to keep
track of these higher moments these
variances
these are also called reynold stresses
uh reynolds stresses because they have
the units of a stress like this
diffusion term here they have a
the they act just like diffusion uh
on the navy or stokes equations so we'll
see that in a little bit
and this is at the heart of the closure
problem
is i'm trying to take this very
complicated equation
that's space and time varying and i'm
trying to get
uh an estimation of how the mean flow
evolve
like like what the mean flow is going to
look like and what the variances and
reynolds stresses are going to look like
without solving this full equation in
space and time everywhere
okay and that's pretty challenging to do
and this is at the heart of what is
known as the closure problem
in turbulence modeling so what we're
going to find when we plug these in
is that there are more unknowns
than equations between u bar
and the u prime squareds and u prime v
prime
time average and u prime w prime time
average and
all of these reynold stresses and their
higher moments there's going to be more
unknowns than there are equations to
uniquely determine those unknowns
and so we're going to have to make
approximations and assumptions kind of
physics engineering modeling assumptions
to build closure models to determine
what those unknown variables are from
the few equations we have
okay that's the rand's closure problem
and
machine learning deep learning in
particular
is starting to give us really powerful
tools for building those approximations
these
for approximating these reynold stresses
uh from other properties of the flow
okay good now i am going to
kind of break this up into pieces
so i set up the problem here this is the
reynolds average navy or stoke problem
we take our navy or stokes equations we
decompose our velocity field into the
sum of an
average component and fluctuating
components
and we're going to plug this in to our
two equations to our
incompressibility and momentum equation
here
okay and in the remainder of this
lecture
i'm going to show you what happens when
i take this
reynolds decomposition and plug it into
my incompressibility
condition and in the next lecture i'm
going to take this same
decomposition and plug it into the full
momentum equation which is much more
complicated
okay so that's what we're going to do so
let's look at this divergence of u
with the reynolds decomposition and
i'm going to use this kind of vector
notation so i can remember
what i'm doing and not mess up so we
have the
divergence of u the whole vector u v w
equals zero and what that implies for me
is that um
partial u bar partial x
plus partial v bar partial y
plus partial w bar partial z
plus partial u prime partial x plus
partial v prime partial y plus partial
w prime partial z uh
in america we call this z equals
zero okay so there's six terms when i
take this divergence
with these six terms and set it equal to
zero
now what's super interesting about this
is that i can actually
learn a lot from this equation by time
averaging it and that's a strategy we're
going to do
we're going to plug this decomposition
into these equations and then we're
going to time average and see what terms
die
so when i time average
again the time average of a derivative
is the derivative of that time
average and the time average of u prime
is zero time average of v
prime is zero time average of w prime is
zero so when i time average
these three terms equal zero
which means that these three terms and
again when i time average these are
unchanged
all of these terms have to equal zero
because when i time average and these go
away
these are the three that are left so
these equal
zero and then by a similar argument if
all of these equal to zero everywhere in
space
it stands to reason that these also add
up to zero in the original equation
so these also add up to zero
and so i've actually derived two very
important conditions from this one
divergence equation
i've learned that the divergence of
u bar the vector this is a little bit
messy
the average of ubar equals
zero the divergence of my mean field
is zero and i've learned that the
divergence of my fluctuating component
is also zero so that's really cool
the mean flow has divergence zero and
the fluctuating component has divergence
zero
and we learn that by plugging this into
the divergence equation
uh the incompressibility equation and
time averaging
okay good so we're going to do the same
thing
with the reynolds decomposition we're
going to plug it into the momentum
equation we're going to time average
we're going to keep track of all of the
terms it's going to be a mess
but kind of fun and we're going to learn
which terms are active which terms go
away and we're going to see a little bit
more what that closure problem looks
like
okay so we're going to kind of derive
this rand's closure model in the next
lecture
let me see should i recap the big idea
it's actually quite simple we have a
turbulent fluid
and we're going to approximate that
turbulent fluid by an
average flow this has lots of properties
we might care about like drag and things
like that
and a bunch of fluctuating components
and we're going to see if we can
simplify the problem by thinking about
it with this decomposition
looking at just the average flow and the
first few moments the variance and the
kurtosis and things like that
of these statistical fluctuations okay
thank you